I'd like to start by thanking
Danielle on Samantha and Phil
for organizing the session.
I am very excited to talk to
you about the privatisation
GitHub and the work
that we have been
doing to aid in the process
of using regulatory setting
and, of course, let you
know how you can contribute.
So this is a quick
overview of my talk.
I'm going to start by telling
you what is our evaluation hub?
I'll go quickly through
the white paper, which
talks about an approach to
assess the accuracy of R
packages with evaluating
infrastructure and following
this white paper and
using this philosophy.
I'm going to introduce you to
two of the tools that we have.
We have been working
on R package colorist
metric and the risk
assessment Shiny application.
And again, I'll provide you
with four other resources
where you can obtain
more information
and how you can be part
of the evaluation GitHub.
And, of course, a
disclaimer they've used,
our thoughts and opinions
expressed in this presentation
belong solely to me and not
necessarily my employers
or organizations or committee.
These are thoughts.
So a little bit about me.
Oh, excuse me.
This is a very out
of the picture.
It looks more like these now.
So I am a pure mathematician
and a data scientist.
I work as an intern for RStudio
with Max Corning, the Titan
model theme.
I enjoy anything after I
have taken the certification
for Shiny five survivors.
And I'm still waiting for Greg
to put out more trainings.
So I can have fun taking them.
I currently work up Biogen in an
awesome team led by Bob ingle,
and I'm also part of
the executive committee
of the Appalachian hub, which
now has eight members this year
of the evaluation harbisson
the vehicles from the escape.
We have members from Merck,
Biogen, gentech, RStudio foster
and the evaluation
GitHub was formed in 2018
and is part of the
Arkansas working group.
We have around hundreds members
from multiple organizations
across the
pharmaceutical sector.
So you can see in the
workload on the right,
our members are Johnson and
Johnson, FDA, Amgen, Eli Lilly
and about hundreds
total members.
Now, the Appalachian GitHub is
set growth industry initiative
to enable the use of R by
the pharmaceutical industry
in that regulatory say,
where the output may
be used in submissions
to regulatory agencies.
Now to support a mission, we
wrote in a white paper title
a risk based approach for
assessing package accuracy,
meaning a value that
validated infrastructure.
This paper was
written by Dinicola
from the ski ollaberry,
from jannsen and Jan
scenes from Pfizer.
And in the name of this paper
is to propose a possible risk
based approach for assessing
our packaged accuracy
with a validated infrastructure.
These white paper
addresses concerns
raised by a statistician,
programmers, quality assurance
teams and others within
the pharmaceutical industry
about the use of our
unselected R packages
as a primary tool for
statistical analysis
for regulatory.
So meachem work.
Now, the white paper space,
or rather the definition
that we use of
validation in the paper
is based on the FDA
definition of validation,
which you can read more
about in the linked article.
And and their validation
can be separating
three main components
accuracy, reproducibility
and traceability
and the white paper.
We focus on accuracy.
We focus on these qualitative
assessment of correctness
or freedom from error.
And the white paper, we
propose a risk based approach
to establish accuracy of those
packages that contributed
packages, and so we
make a distinction
between core prices, contributed
R packages and packages.
We say there are
those packages that
are part of the official
distribution as formerly
released by the foundation.
So these are so very
commonly referred
to as base are Bloss
recommended packages.
Now these packages are
considered to be low risk.
And we make this
determination based
on how their foundation
develops our language.
You can read more about how
their foundation describes the
and how their foundation takes
their approach to developing
their language, their
testing approach,
and how the operations
in the link document.
And we can bring
these documents.
You may agree with us
that the team controls are
like any of the
companies that produces
the commercial software that
you may buy in this space.
So the packages are the core.
Our packages are
very well control.
And so can be considered
to be low risk.
Now, the complement we
have those packages that
are contributed
that I meant that
are made by the community, which
are about 70,000 packages now,
krahn.
And the risk of
these packages really
depend on various
factors like how well
is the package you develop?
Is it well tested?
The banks may have a burien
software development life
cycles.
They should be aware.
And you also can check
for how much exposure
has their package had
within the user community.
And in the White
paper, we propose,
as I mentioned, an
approach to assess
the accuracy of the conjugated
packages as those core.
I considered to be low risk.
So once someone in
your company wants
to use one of these
contributed packages,
the question is,
what steps can you
take to Sa to assess the
risk of those packages.
So the white paper can be
in taking the first steps
to start assessing the
risk of using on R package.
So once you have decided that
you want to use a package,
the next step that we
propose for you to do
is to assess the package based
on four criteria crippen's
maintainance, good practice,
community use and testing.
And so when talking
about purpose,
it is assumed that any package
that we're talking about
is intended to be used
within a workflow.
So package directly manipulating
data, creating graphics
or running a
statistical model that
forms part of the solution,
referring to those.
So in terms of risk, any package
should be weighted equally.
But we do recognize that
modeling statistical packages
deserve a special attention.
And we know that there's
any need difficulty
to identify errors
in those packages,
in those small packages versus
those say that manipulate data.
So, for instance,
if you would like
to test their range
function of the blyer,
it is easy to do or you can
or relatively easy to do.
You can use a small data
set to test this function
and check that the corresponding
column has been sorted
correctly, on the other
hand, and statistical models
are harder to test.
And a statistician can really
check that a model is correct.
But not correct to
the decimal places.
Now, in terms of
mountainous good practice,
it's good to address
the questions
on how is the documentation
of the package?
Is the source code on
GitHub or any other medium?
And we do know that
when you expose
a package to the community,
you helps reduce the risk,
even if the package has
no test that is popular
and nobody has been widely
used by the community.
And so lastly, testing
is a crucial part
of the aclc in another
mundaneness best practice
metric.
In general, the white paper
proposes this workflow,
which you are encouraged
to read more website, which
I'm going to provide a link to
the end of the presentation.
Now before showing you
that they are working on.
I want to point out
a misconception.
We're talking about
open source software
like are I supposed to know
that no statistical software can
purchase us pre
validated software
in this regulatory context?
So what happened
is that valuation
is up to the user to implement.
So, for instance, Sas is not
a pre validated software.
However, given the
dominance of some
of these soldiers
in the industry,
many companies have
collected evidence
through a long period
of time that details
the testing and validation
of functions, procedures, et
cetera.
And so when you
use the software,
rather than
reinventing the wheel
and duplicating deathin,
which has already performed
in the past by others,
we make the decision
to use that software based on
its history of extensive use
as we decide to do with Sas
procedures, for instance.
So following this
philosophy, you
can see our practice as
having received validation
through a variety of
sources, validation
by the original
authors of the package,
by users of the
package and academia,
by users in a wide variety
of industries like Google,
sole Microsoft by companies
such as mongul solutions
and even by the FDA themselves,
who have been using knowledge.
Now for some time.
So in the same way that we can
trust a long standing nakash,
we can start thinking about
R packages in the same way.
So if we want to if we
believe this to be the case,
then we need to look
at which packages
we can add to our safe list.
To do that, we have been working
on their metric, our package,
which follows a philosophy
in the white paper
and tries to answer questions
like who are the authors?
How many times has the
package been downloaded?
Does the package
is a package test?
What is the best
kodesh of the package?
Is the source code public?
And so are mattrick is on
our package, which measures
the risk of using packages.
And this risk is
calculated based
on a number of metrics that are
meant to evaluate development,
best practices, code,
documentation, development,
sustainability and
community engagement.
Now it's important to note that
this risk there is portrayed
by risk metric does not
represent the risk of damaging
the system in which the
package is in store or the risk
that internal and statistical
functions are correct.
Although indirectly,
the package does
show that this
California cigarette,
by looking at the testing on
the community use and the bug
reports and so on.
So if you apply, there is
magic, R package to hublot,
you will obtain a low risk.
So the lowest risk, the
risk ranges from 0 to 1 0
mean the lowest risk, one being
the higher risk, the highest
risk that you can get.
Where ggplot your
obtain point to?
So that is a low risk.
And if you use a new
package like rules
from the tity models, which I
said, you created this year,
if I'm not mistaken,
you were a high risk.
And of course,
getting high risk will
point you to in which
you have to look
for there in the package, like,
do you have to create test?
Do you have to provide
more documentation?
But in general,
this doesn't mean
that you can't use the package,
but rather that probably you
have to make more tests.
And so let's take a look at the
functions inside this metric
or the main functions.
And I say mention the package is
on GitHub in the link provided.
Feel free to contact
us to contribute.
We're always looking for people
to help out build this package.
And so if the package is
on github, as I mentioned,
I'm not done yet.
And so once we solved the
package using their tools
and you it, you can
follow our workflow,
which starts by finding a
source for package information.
You send the package
reference function
and you will look for packages
in small local install
or gron or get.
Once you have applied the
package reference function,
you can move on to assess.
So what that will do is look
at the different metrics
and find information.
For the different metrics,
for the metrics, vineyards
and currents and so on.
And lastly, you can
apply the patches
for a function, which will
ask for the package based
on the assessment
quickly on those metrics.
So then the results will be
assembled in a data set that
contains the entire risk.
And the other metrics.
So as you can see below, you
will see the output of metrics
for to improve how it looks.
Let's use cable extra.
And there you can see
the different metrics.
So we have, for
instance, so each column
is information, some new
information about the package
and the roles.
We have particular packages.
So we have to applaud rules.
You can see the version
that we are assessing,
the risk aspect,
ratio and risk metric.
They don't load on this
for one year, which
shows the percentage of
the number of downloads
in the last year.
So you can see how much has
been downloaded versus rules.
And so on.
Now to as you can see, reading
the metrics on this table,
although we have used Google X
rays, maybe hard to understand,
and you can not interact with
the race and with the packages.
So to provide a
better user interface
to deal with the
risk, we have been
working on a shiny application
called a risk assessment
application, which provides
you a frame frame where you
interact with the
risk, provide comments,
you can create reports.
And also you can imagine.
And you can take a bunch
of using chinee meaning
that you don't need to code.
You don't need to be called
a financial service metric
and you have an interactive
way to measure risk.
So I'm going to do
something risky.
I'm going to try to show you
how the application looks
like a lift them up.
The application is on GitHub.
And feel free to reach
out to us to contribute.
We have meetings weekly.
And you can join us.
The link to do that
is on our website.
So let me try to switch to
other window, see how that goes.
Alexey the.
OK, OK, perfect.
So once you load
the application,
this is how it look like.
You can provide a user ibnr
role when you click Proceed
to the application, you
can upload the package.
And the structure
of this file is.
So you can see
here on the screen,
you can download this
template and use it
for the application for the
sake of time, I have uploaded.
Three packages, so we
take a look at the flyer,
for instance, you will
see the same metrics
that we saw on the
table for three here,
but you will have more
information into other metrics
mean.
And instead of
seeing point nine,
you will see a percentage,
as you would expect to do.
So I will tell you
just how much icing
is current, how many
exported objects that are.
I will tell you the percentage
of closure that we had him on.
And so you do this,
when you can also
look at the number of downloads
in the last six months, one
year, and you can see that
the pie is wildly popular.
And so you can provide
comment on the metrics.
And once you hear
my comments and are
happy with how the
metrics are portrayed
or the risk of the package,
you can provide an overall risk
low, maybe on a high,
depending on address certain
of the package.
And after you do that, you can
download a report containing
all the metrics, the
number of downloads
and your comments
on the package.
So the application has
other functionalities
that you can play around with.
And again, the
application is on github,
so you can feel free to do so.
So let me switch back
to the presentation.
And Katie.
So I'll see.
One officer I1.
Kayna I can see if I can do the.
Well, school.
So I you can you check with me
that you can see the screen?
So I don't see
anything yet here.
What if I tried to
read you as presenter?
Be sure that do
something different.
Here, let me quickly try that.
We have an.
Presenter usually life
segments don't go very well,
so but it's good
to give it a try.
I wanted you to take a look
at the application totally.
I appreciate your bravery,
but some of the things
you can see now, right?
Yes that looks great.
Now Awesome.
So that's application again.
Feel free to go to
GitHub and play around
with the application, provide
feedback or any new features.
And so on to find out
more how all these tools,
you can go to the
farma website where
you can see the blog
Bolls presentations
and the white paper.
Also, feel free to
join our mailing list.
And you can send a message
to our or the email provider
on the slide to contribute.
And also, if you want
to learn more detail
about the white
paper on these tools,
we did a workshop
last year, farmer
and in there is a
link on the slides,
the slides a little
bit later where
you have the video to the
workshop and testing exercises
that we did during the workshop.
And I like to end by
thanking the evaluation
GitHub and the contributors
of the risk metrics package
dog Dylan, Eric, Eli.
And I'm pretty sure I'm missing
some Rogers, and consumer.
A risk assessment package,
the risk assessment excuse me,
application, especially
to Aaron and Meyer,
who have been working with
me on the application.
And I'd like to Thank
you to our sooyoung
for organizing these
pharma excession
and told you for coming to this.
Thank you.